[Music]
this week the Jim Henson Company said
they would no longer allow its puppets
to promote the fast food company
chick-fil-a after the founder of
chick-fil-a came out against
homosexuality yeah so but this has not
stopped chick-fil-a they just came out
with a new puppet to spread the word
about their delicious chicken sandwiches
and homophobia
please welcome Chaz the intolerant
chick-fil-a chicken father hi there
everybody don't forget there's only one
great chicken sandwich and only one way
to love okay I'm sorry
Chaz that sounds a little intolerant
it's in Scripture the only pickle of God
should put in his mouth is our
chick-fil-a clapping you made your point
we got it ladies if you want to talk
valid make it our southwestern
chargrilled town with garlic and
buttered croutons yeah fine Thank You
Chaz please hey dudes if you want warm
nuts all over your face there's only one
choice our chick-fil-a hot fudge sundae
stop stop right now hey if you want hot
meat stuck between two buns
covered in soft the way God meant it to
be enjoy its chick-fil-a or the flames
of hey you don't you godless thought of
mine can you say eat up you godless God
like the mites